hello everyone welcome to today's live
broadcast importance and effect of
surgical training skills and experience
on performing surgical procedures within
studies I am finding kelly kim of lab
groups and i'll be your moderator for
today's event we have a few important
announcements before we begin this
webcast is designed to be interactive
and we encourage you to ask questions
during the event you can submit
questions by typing them in the Q&A box
which can be found by clicking on the
green Q&A button at the lower left of
the presentation window we'll try to
answer as many questions as we can you
can enlarge the slide window by clicking
on the screen icon in the lower right
hand corner of the slide window
hello everyone welcome to today's live
broadcast important and effect of
surgical training skills and experience
on performing surgical procedures within
studies I am finding kelly kim of lab
groups and i'll be your moderator for
today's event we have a few important
announcements before we begin this
webcast is designed to be interactive
and we encourage you to ask questions
during the event you can submit
questions by typing them in the Q&A box
which can be found by clicking on the
green Q&A button at the lower left of
the presentation window we'll try to
answer as many questions as we can you
can enlarge the slide window by clicking
on the screen icon in the lower right
hand corner of the slide window if you
have any technical problems viewing or
hearing this presentation please click
on the support button at the top right
of your presentation window or submit
your problem through the green Q&A
button lower left I would now like to
introduce today's speaker Delphine booya
he received her doctorate in veterinary
medicine from the veterinary school of
Leo she is currently working at the
surgery consultant for veggies she has
experience working with animal suppliers
pharma companies diverse CR OHS medical
device suppliers vital text as well as
universities and vet school I will now
turn it over to dr. booya for her
presentation thank you very much Brenda
for this introduction and I would like
also to thank the laboratory animal
science board for their invitation I'm
actually very happy to have the
opportunity to talk about training in
surgery I'm working for more than 12
years now in the laboratory animal
science area with the focus on surgery
and I had the opportunity to develop new
models with several teams and the least
I can say is that training when it comes
to developing numerals in surgery is
really a key to success and by success I
mean respecting animal welfare
in compliant with the three Earth's
principles and really performing good
science when starting to work on a
challenging surgical model you might
think that animal survival is the goal
well in my opinion is definitely not
because performing the science actually
means making every effort to control or
eliminate non-experimental variables
when it comes to surgery and immediate
in variables means producing highly
emerging arrows batches of operated
animals so being in the green area on
the slide and when you start working
with the model and you just get good
survival rate or good success rate and
by success I mean for example getting
good pattern see rates with vascular
catheters you're usually quite still
quite far away from highly emotional
spaces you still have to go through
quite a lot of training and actually
it's quite easy to underestimate the the
need for training with several surgical
models first of all you may lost
information along the line usually
initially the surgical models are
developed with by people with good
experience by experts but then
definitely information can get lost when
people are trying to teach each other a
technique they learn from the initial
expert then you can also take over
mistakes of your teacher if your teacher
is not working according
state-of-the-art techniques it happens
sometimes and the best thing is that
once you have bad habits it's very
difficult to get rid of them for example
if you are time in proper nuts and
believe me there are many many people
doing that it is very very hard to get
rid of this bad habit who needs to be
trained actually I will go into deep
details describing what is on this table
is just generality regarding our staff
working in this area and and developing
new curricle models
and please don't be mad at me if you are
a technician with very high skills I
know that there are many of you again
it's just generality the key message
beyond this slide is that everybody
needs to Train even if you have a very
good surgical background when you have
to learn a completely new surgical model
you have to train and I will give you a
very personal example I worked actually
for Charles River as surgery unit
manager for several years I was hired
there in 2007 and before that i was
performing surgery on a regular basis
experimental surgery on a regular basis
for already five years almost on a daily
basis so I had good basic surgical
skills but I had to learn how to implant
catheter in rodents I and I have never
done that before so I had to learn how
to work under the microscope how to
handle rodent vessels and it actually
took me months and several training
session to reach the success rate and
the speed of the technician working
there for years it was really different
from whatever I have been doing before
and it took me much more time that I
would have expected and it wasn't even
highly challenging model it was
challenged model but not highly
challenging ones in experimental surgery
the actual difficulty and associated
requested training is actually highly
variable of course it is really not the
same thing to learn how to put to put an
implant circuit now see and to perform a
liver transplant when you try when you
are trying to develop and to learn how
to perform the highly challenging model
you better go through a lot of training
sessions before and you better be
performing accessible or challenging
models for months or years there is
really absolutely no way to start from
scratch with for example people not
knowing how to type a surgical nut and
directly go to highly changing the
models I believe me I've been asked
several
time to train people without surgical
background to do for example myocardial
infarction in mice there is no way to do
that you have to go step by step and
only people with a very good theoretical
background can go to highly challenging
models now let's say that you are a good
trainer with the good skills and you are
working according state of your
technique and you have people to train
and they also have the right skills to
train the model you have to teach them
how would you build your training
program how my suggestions what up I
would always start with a theoretical
training I think it's very important for
people to be trained to understand the
context of the experiment what is the
goal of the surgery in most cases
surgery is actually a way to
precondition the animal for the
experiment and they're really I think
it's very important for people to
understand why they are doing this fury
and what is the general context what is
the final goal of the project they
should also have a good knowledge of the
anatomy of the organs they will work
with and they should also understand the
physiological changes that will be that
will be the consequences of the surgery
in my experience people who have this
knowledge about the context about the
anatomy about the physiology they learn
much faster and they get much better
success rate once you go through this
theoretical training steps then you can
go on with the end zone training and
this anthem could actually be ex vivo or
inveigle and I will elaborate a little
bit more that with the following slides
but the important thing is that during
these and some training steps people
will have to repeat a certain amount of
time some key gestures like for example
for a myocardial infraction model how to
the gate a coronary artery the number of
key gestures
repetition can be pretty predefined when
you build your training program but it
should remain very flexible because you
will experience that people are not
training honor turning the same way it's
very good to actually adapt to a program
to the actual surgeons progresses at the
end of your training steps so
theoretical training and then ends on
one you can eventually go through a
validation exam I think it's it's quite
interesting this is something we worked
on with Charles River surgery team the
ID was the following people were allowed
to train on a certain number of cadavers
inert models or animals after their
theoretical training and once they were
already once they really think that they
know how to perform the surgery they
were allowed to pass an exam during the
exam they had to operate a certain
number of animals like two or three for
example the trainer was on their back
watching the wolf surgery if everything
was ok during the surgery then the
animals were allowed to recover and then
they were followed up during an
appropriate follow-up period during
which few success criterion were
followed up as well and at the end of
the procedure the animal of the
follow-up time period sorry the animals
will be sanitized and an extra key will
be will be performed if everything was
ok during the surgery during the
postoperative observations and if
nothing wrong was seen during the
necrosis and the surgeons were
considered as validated and they could
then prepare animals for a customer
batches it sounds a little bit
complicated but it's actually not that
much it's it's quite fun and it was
extremely efficient to validate these
training programs back to the two steps
of the hands-on training ex-vivo or n0 I
think it's people tend to skip the xvii
buffets and it's a shame because there
are many many key gestures of surgery
that could be trained with inert
such as the MVP vco as you can see on
the picture of sauropods for example
suitors definitely but also honest
really I de a highly difficult suitor
such as anastomoses can be trained in
this kind of with this kind of system
and especially the MVP we here at
working under a microscope can be
trained with this kind of device as well
so it's really very interesting and you
can really reduce the number of animal
needed for a training by using this kind
of systems of course there are
situations when you really have to train
on living animals for example if you
have to implant a telemetry device in
the infrarenal abdominal oughta you need
to check at the end of your implantation
that there is no bleeding that there is
no leakage that the signal that you are
recording is okay and when you do blood
vessel arrest the movies you need to
check at the end of the procedure that
there is no blood leakage so they are
they are definitely models for which you
need to go through individual phases you
have no choice and let's work on one
specific example this example is
actually a kidney transplant example
learning phase examples it was published
in the late 90s and so the goal was to
try to reach an acceptable skinnier time
acceptable by acceptable I mean Anna
scania time that although the animal to
properly recover and and the kidney to
be a functional so here and you cannot
see that are on the shame first of all
the student who was actually a medical
doctor with already some surgical
experience trained on 95 rats really to
understand the different steps of the
procedure and
read worse than what he had to do with
the animals once he went through this
initial training he had another 48
animals in order to understand how to
work on the other microscopes and then
he was using other animals once he was
really ready to go he already was able
to perform the world procedure and able
to work under the microscope then he
started to record the number of animals
he was using and ischemia Thailand these
are the red dots you can see on the
shame as you can see 95 animals were
used initially than 48 others and then
all the numbers all the figures
mentioned on close to the red dots it's
a total of 238 rats two key messages
beyond this slide this slight sorry
first of all as you can see when it
comes to highly challenging models the
number of key gestures repetition to
reach a success rate might be really a
huge other observation it's a tradition
because there are many many steps in
view assess that should that could have
been replaced by x0 steps a lot of the
different steps of sorry a lot of these
steps could have been trained actually
on MVP VCH for example I mean working
under the microscope you don't need to
do that in living animals and same for
the initial 95 lat I'm sure that many
many steps could have been straight
rained on in earth models so don't keep
the X zero phase and keep in mind that
for highly challenging models the number
of key gesture repetition could be very
very high so let's no let's describe two
examples of our training models of
training programs sorry and let's start
with the basic model or at least model
that seems basic the Sudanese
implantation of a continuous infusion
device
in zucca rat there are a few nations to
be understood pre requested surgical
skills and the number of ki jaya
gestures repetition is not very I I
mentioned three to six on the slide
because the surgery is quite basic okay
it looks basic but again you have to
work with zucca rats hazard animals and
these are animals for which you may have
to adapt the surgical technique but also
the pre and post-operative care for
example these are animals very sensitive
to some anesthetics and they also quite
often have impaired will eating so you
should add up the way that russ tutoring
the skin and you should also adapt the
post-operative follow-up so here are in
blue my suggestions for the training
program few hours of theory during which
I will insist on a septic techniques and
strange specificities then a hands-on
technique on cadavers and run technique
on get over again and non survival
series and then eventually the
validation exam so it's a total of 14
hours to survival surgeries and true
story I'm comparing that with something
that happened at Eve actually I think
slightly underestimated the need for
training for this model thinking that it
was very easy and immediately started to
prepare a batch for an experiment out of
20 animals prepared 15 had
post-operative problems or died during
the anesthesia because actually the
program was not fully adapted the
protocol story was not fully adapted so
as you can imagine repeating the
experiment was really a problem and when
you compare the time and the effort that
would have been spent to completely
repeat the study as compared to what I'm
suggesting in terms of initial training
I think it's it should be a shame to
have underestimated
for training again for this basic model
now let's move to a more challenging one
myocardial infraction in mice by
legation of the left descending coronary
artery very challenging model the
surgery has to be performed after so i
go to me in a bitty out of the mice it's
really very school you have to be
extremely precise again you can
definitely not trained people without
very very good basic skills they cannot
learn the surgery so people should start
with a very very good surgery level I
will go into the details describe
describing the different steps of the
program I wrote in blue I would say that
the key messages beyond these slides are
that here as you can see there are some
very specific key gestures to be learned
like incubation chest opening called
coronary artery ligation and chess
tutoring and unfortunately those these
technical gestures they need to check on
living animals they're absolutely you
can you can initially trained on
cadavers of course but to be under
percent sure that you are doing the
gestures properly you need to let the
animals recover and check that there are
ok if you go through appropriate ex vivo
steps you can really reduce the number
of animals and in the program and
suggesting you're only using only it's
already quite a lot that I think it's
minimal 25 server survival sharee the
thing is that if you did something wrong
and it would happen during a training
phase with the intubation again the
chest opening the radiation or the
suturing the animals could be eventually
suffering they could be insane or they
could even die so the very one thing
that is really a very important is to
define relevant endpoints you should
really while preparing your training
program identified what can go
wrong with these key gestures and define
a endpoint that are adapted and really
prepare a very good full program and
make sure that if something went from
the animal will be humanity sanitized on
time again a true story about something
that happened surgeons with a very very
good surgical experience had a demand
for the preparation of 200 animals for a
study they went through a quite shocked
training program and so that it was
enough so they started their experiment
again with their 200 animals but
unfortunately they went they they had to
go through a learning phase and the last
almost 80 animals going through this
learning discerning phase again because
of the of the very challenging key
gestures I just mentioned so actually 80
animals is not that bad as compared to
the number of requested key gestures
mentioned in the program but they had to
explain to their customers because it
was hero that they again had to repeat
the experiment because actually they
more or less did their training were
preparing this badge for an experiment
so again I think that organizing and
preparing good training program can
really save a lot of animals and proven
people for very bad events such as this
one okay is one good initial training
enough well not necessarily if you have
to do again have to perform challenging
models but you don't have the
opportunity to perform them on a very
regular basis then you can lose skills
it's well known that the elf's lifetime
of theoretical knowledge is approximate
is up
approximately 180 days and after three
years globally all knowledge is gone
what about practical skills well
according to my experience depending on
the difficulty of the model you really
start to lose gears after a three to six
months meaning that you may have to
retrain after these time periods again
back to the example of Charles River
surgery team we defined retraining
programs and depending on the the model
can be performed we have the surgeons to
retrain it could be a very fast very
quickly training like in one or two
animals or in one or two cadavers before
they start again preparing the badge
because what you don't want to do is to
to perform surgeries following the blue
curve you can see on the on the shame
the thing is that if you didn't perform
a surgery for a while and you do it
again and you have to do to go through a
learning phase again and you will start
your surgery in the morning and
eventually you will spend one hour in
your animal and then integral ago better
and better during the day and eventually
at the end of the day it will take you
20 minutes to do the same surgery it
means that the batch of animals you will
have prepared is highly an emoji nails
and it this is really not something you
want to do you want to be as close as
possible to the red line on the shame so
retraining is really a good way to avoid
going through this blue line again just
for your information there are general
rules in this field for example in
hospitals nurses that are not practicing
the specific technique for a while like
for more than one year they have to
train under the supervision of an
experienced person before being allowed
to do these gestures again on their own
okay so now that you've done your your
followed up you followed up your nice
training program and eventually you
build up a nice retraining program are
you done well not really I think you
should also think about building a
continuous training program why do I
mean by that the idea is that in surgery
when you perform a surgery on a very
regular basis you never stop improving
your technique usually you'll never see
you you're you're faster and faster with
the tail with the technique you are
creating less and less trauma and this
is something I really really like the
surgery you never stop learning you
always do better when you practice a lot
and the very best way to make sure that
these efforts and these improvements are
saved is to keep recalled because when
you gain in speed when you create less
trauma it's because you're doing
something better and usually it's very
small things like placing your future
slightly differently handing your
instrument spicy and I think it's really
very very interesting 244 surgeons who
keep record of what they are doing and
also keep regards of the outcomes what
is going on after the surgery okay if I
do that if I slightly change that what
is going on afterwards is it all out the
animals recovering faster is my surgery
faster as well so all these little seems
there are a lot of little details that
make the difference in surgery and you
should really keep free cause of them
the other interest of keeping records is
to prevent technical trysts it happens
sometimes you you you really have the
right gestures and then you change
things slightly and then you end up with
problems and you don't understand why
recording all details of the way you are
performing the surgery and especially
when it's performed with success is the
best way to prevent these technical
trips both
ready follower but as just mentioned is
really a key of course you want to
record what you are doing there is a
during the surgery but also the outcomes
necropsies is also something extremely
useful sometimes you can perform a
necropsy on the animals you've operated
because there they are actually involved
in a study and you cannot see them
anymore after the surgery but if you
have the opportunity or if you have few
extra animals that are actually not
involved in the experiment in which you
can perform the crocuses it's also a
very good way to check on what you did
the level of detail image you created
and if your little step by step
improvements are having riddles so what
are the takeaway messages first of all
do not train yourself and select your
teacher carefully work with people who
are really working according to state of
the air or technique because again if
you start working with bad techniques if
you have better bits it would be very
very difficult to get rid of them learn
from the best and as just mentioned the
best way to do that is to keep record of
what you are doing of what you are doing
and of what the outcomes are once is not
enough in many many cases the more you
practice the best you will get and again
in surgery you never ever stop learned
train train and retrain when needed if
you didn't perform a surgery for a few
months think about retraining on few
animals before preparing an animal for
an experiment and again because you have
to practice so much because you have to
train and retrain use in vitro
techniques whenever possible to be
compliant with the reduction principle
there are many many things that could be
done ex vivo as a conclusion i will
first of all thank the laboratory animal
science board again and especially chip
and baron who helped me to build this
presentation as well as professor of
anatomy from the Ranieri me surgical
science center in the Netherlands who
helped me a lot as well and working with
vaniya quite often and you kindly
reviewed this presentation and the
surgery teens of Charles River I
mentioned several time during the
presentation please don't forget that
survival alone is not enough it's
definitely not enough what you want is
to produce highly emotional speeches for
the experiments that should really be
your goal thank you very much
you
thank you Delphine for that informative
presentation before we get started on
the question and answer session I would
like to remind our audience how to
submit questions you can submit
questions by typing them in the Q&A box
which can be found by clicking on the
green Q&A button at the lower left of
the presentation window we'll try to
answer as many questions as we can
you
in addition I would like to let the
audience members know that PDF versions
of the slides from this presentation are
available by clicking on the file button
or you can log out of the presentation
log back in and find it in our Resource
Center if you would like to use any of
the PDF of the slides from this
presentation
and we're going to wrap it up there
again no thank our audience members and
Delphine boo gr for her wonderful
presentation and her participation in
today's event today's webcast will be
available for on-demand viewing through
August 2015 and you'll receive an email
from lab roots alerting you when this
webcast will be available for replay we
invite you to forward that to
announcement to your colleagues who may
have missed today's live event thank you
very much see you next time bye Thank
You Brenda fight